hello everyone i'm in iceland
we just landed uh we rented a car
marseille is here i brought her along
you know
i let her come this trip and now we're
gonna drive to reykjavik
we're at the hotel it's about 5 30. it's
a really cozy hotel
we got a little window here which you
can climb out of
if you want to
definitely a good idea i don't think i
was supposed to do this
mattia can you help me
i bought this katla
named after the mother of icelandic
volcanoes
if you're swedish you know cat lies like
that creepy dragon from
brunelle
oh brother leon yeah of course i love
them
cat lion was the dragon i was so scared
of kevlar
a little bit
that's very nice probably the best thing
about iceland so far is the internet
it's really fast
oh
holy this internet is amazing how
is this
hotel internet i just had to go to
iceland to get proper internet how about
that god damn boy this is so bizarre
because i really feel like i'm in sweden
right now
but something went horribly wrong i'm
joking
it's very nice i really like it i feel
like home
we're just walking to the city center we
don't really know where we're just
guessing we're following the church
gonna hit that god church am i right
marzia
she says yes everybody we found the
guard church
we're gonna get on top of it and we're
gonna dab on all the icelandic haters
[Music]
we're going to the top that was so cool
by the way
i didn't expect this okay
i have to hold on to stand up here
incredible it's less windy here
it's so nice and sunny but it's really
cold
just like sweden i'm home goddammit i
just realized i forgot to dab on them
damn it where am i saying
[Music]
i'm free i find annoying
look at that i found you oh my god
i didn't realize what the hell is that
i just walked
good job
amazing i'm clapping i feel so icelandic
with these ice glasses
and ice glasses eye glasses
sunglasses shut up your new nose can be
torn a
[Music]
oh wow where did my jacket go that's so
weird
i am so excited because they have proper
fish soup here
like the real the real deal it's not as
good as sweden
how is it so light outside i forgot oh
yeah we're in iceland
it's like light all the time eight
o'clock isn't it
what it's eight o'clock it's nine
o'clock can you believe it's
nine and it's so bright it's a snake
it's a snake everybody guys if you go
near me
i will kill you i will dab on you
you hater
oh my god that's terrifying i'm really
loving iceland so far
i keep getting recognized even though
i'm like this i don't believe it like
how
one guy was like i recognize your beard
but everyone is really lovely everyone's
really nice it's really cool
i ate way too much food man
oh my god yes
oh my god yeah we had some
extra time this morning and we decided
to go to this whale museum
it's not really planned but it's really
cool
[Music]
cool it's a narwhal
damn
[Music]
we're going on a helicopter tour
they said it was a bit windy that's why
they delayed it this morning
so and it is really windy so
we just gone die there's our helicopter
here we go i'm super excited
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god my legs are all shaky
it's windy apparently we're walking to
mordor
jesus
i think these rocks are hot oh it feels
hot
ah
[Music]
did you enjoy that yeah it was cool i'm
a little motion sick but it was really
fun it was super fun
the scenery was amazing
even my beard is like going everywhere
this restaurant is so cool you see all
of iceland
and they have fish soup
this is the best food
[Music]
uk you suck at fish i'm i'm gonna say it
now that's right
i guess today is like the scenic day
because we're doing all this
visual stuff tomorrow we're doing more
hardcore stuff i'm so happy whenever i
get a beer in a fish soup and i'm just
like
i feel good
[Music]
hey what's up it's like walking into a
like walking into a fridge
um my hat
oh my goodness it's cool very cool
spooky
my nose is so red
oh my god they're so cool okay should we
just go
yeah it's just too cold
ah i never want to be calm again
it feels so good to be out we really
just stopped for food but we got a
little
glacier toured as well very nice
we're doing the golden circle well
that's going to take
five hours but she doesn't nice nine
we are here at the first stop at the
geyser this is what it's like
smells very nice you feel that sulfur
smell
it just went off
that's so cool so that's the big one
the big gay sir we just missed it
i mean i saw it you guys missed it what
i don't care about you guys okay so we
reached
the end of the circle so we have the
exact same amount of time
back i don't know why i'm saying this
because it doesn't matter you we're at
our
second destination which is the
waterfall gulfosh which i think means
golden
falls maybe this is so cool
oh my god i'm getting water splashed in
my face
whoa that's so cool
oh my god i'm getting so wet
that's insane
how's the battery going
so pretty i never ever expected to see
something like this
i don't know if you can hear me but it's
cool
[Music]
today was such a memorable nice day
i think now we're gonna hope for some
northern lights because we're up pretty
late
probably not we're not gonna see
anything but we have an equally exciting
day tomorrow
and i'll see you then can't really see
it on camera
but it's there
i see them oh
is it better oh i see them
that's cool oh
oh my god so blurry
okay
really see them
oh cool
like a damn thing
okay so we're going whale hunting now
hunting we're gonna kill the whales now
turn left
after we turn left and then right the
whales will die
apparently there's a running thing going
on
called marathon i don't know but we
gotta walk
the finals bet we're here at the harbor
okay we're all dressed up
do
[Music]
we just bought it
nice they show themselves so
briefly it's hard to capture them
[Music]
nice
sake
[Music]
that was really cool you loved it
we saw a couple whales got a nice boat
ride
yeah i'm freezing it's very cold but it
was very nice
now we're going to the blue lagoon which
you may have seen like
all the celebrities go to anyway
it looks like we're driving at this like
car commercial road right now
you want to buy the new kia pewdiepie
drives the kia
i don't drive a kia but if you want to
pay me
and how can i forget it's our
anniversary
six year anniversary so we're going to a
nice restaurant that's really good as
well
we're going to the evil villain lair or
what's happening
okay so we're in the blue lagoon and
we're in this
private area and like we have our own
it's very nice very nice
oh it's hot it's really hot
yeah so it's he said between 38
to 40 degrees oh i feel so
oh did i not do that oops
i'm sorry excellent
you like this you like this my fan
i look like a wet cat
[Applause]
oh my god it feels so good oh it's cold
the contrast of cotton my god it's so
amazing look
[Music]
we're outside
i love this so nice
oh my god it's like heaven
can i float what's in there not really
it's what i expected and more
[Music]
how do i look this is the same stuff
that's in the water
this is my thumbnail i feel like we've
been here for a couple hours now it's
dark
[Music]
it's so nice i love this
oh my god my hair i think
we're going home now we're leaving
tomorrow but this is an amazing trip
i really really really loved iceland it
was amazing
and i hope you enjoyed coming along
leave a
like for more vlogs
bye
[Laughter]
it's like